pas sur les notes 1 celle de la culture
réunionnaise
impliquer chacun est une vache à lait de
la culture
je suis marie-paule deltour ce hangar
hanuman je suis né à champ-borne colosse
je suis présidente d'une association
folklorique can do
bienvenue chez moi la résidence d'alto
siège de l'association
l'association été créée en 1995
alors la can do on a donné ce nom à
notre association folklorique c'est une
belle plante qui fleurit toutes les
vérandas de la réunion et on en a fait
un logo je suis métisse d'origine
indienne et écrire le blanc
déjà un petit stick mans c'était un peu
dans le patrimoine familial
et j'ai exercé
des chorégraphies au sein de la troupe
folklorique de la réunion on sent que
c'est une activité qui cheveux
réunionnaise c'est à dire métis
essentiellement métis il ya certains la
réunion qui ont des identités
administrative d'autres qui parce que ou
ne reconnaît pas leur identité
réunionnaise et le prennent une identité
culturelle l'ambiance malien dans la
case
voilà donc avec notre leur qui fait son
rythme de coeur qui bat on va poser les
pieds bien cherché le sol
les quais sont bien posés au sol
le costa c'était un manque d'animations
sur les sites touristiques
établissements hôteliers c'était dommage
pour la promotion de l'île de la réunion
si c'est le stock ici c'est toutes les
archives toute la vie administrative
financière de l'association
on alla petit costume gris ici diversité
des costumes c'est en rapport avec nos
tableaux multiethnique donc chaque
tableau à ses costumes appropriés
chemisier abbas
transformation pour le panneau indien
donc c'est ce qui m'a amené en fait dans
l'association
je faisais la danse indienne en fait et
c'est la fille de marie paule qui m'a
remarqué donc j'ai atterri dans can do
on m'a dit tu fais de la danse indienne
et après battu mais une jupe et tu vas
dans sega maloya
et du coup j'ai appris sur le tas j'ai
adoré et les jeux c'est encore ce sont
des artistes animés d'une même passion
qui est défendent le patrimoine culturel
de la réunion sa musique ses danses sa
gastronomie mais ti mois ces
enseignantes et mon but aussi à l'école
c'est aussi de montrer notre culture aux
enfants et on a mis l'accent là-dessus
transmettre pédagogiquement transmettent
à culture pour passer sous les 10
allez allons allons
né à l'école chocas la plaine village de
la plaine on attend les enfants pour
aller faire les activités au case de la
plaine qui est un peu plus bas les
attend ici on le rendez vous se passe
sous l'arbre effectivement
je vous donne vos cahiers d'activités
culturelles
avec tous les instruments et on va faire
d'autres beaux dessins et du coloriage
c'est la culture mais ils connaissent
pas
le maloya le cadre i on est athée avenue
dans différentes écoles sur la partie
indienne qui était aussi intéressante
ils ont beaucoup aimé je préfère plus
tout ce qu'il fit tradition
parce que c'est ça notre race in the
c'est notre culture c'est notre histoire
donc la perpétuer il trouve que c'est
c'est mieux que de prendre tout ce qui
vient de l'extérieur et
de s'imprégner de ce qui vient de
l'extérieur tout ce qu'une fois qu'ils
sont qui sortent de lille qui vont faire
des études ailleurs c'est là qu'ils
questionnent que je reçois des mails me
disant madame aidez nous
on se rend compte qu'on ne connaît pas
notre culture
nous fêtons ce n'est pas
quelque chose
qu'on ne peut approuver un homme bloqué
pour moi
latine et immédiate même s'il envoie le
souligne thomas v
la noce
elle y rencontre beaucoup de difficultés
et et croit koala qui tient les lunettes
la preuve on offin l'associaton attend
madame pas satisfait mais je vais
transmettre d'autres antennes qui
verront le jour également cette année
c'est à dire qu'on ira chercher les
enfants défavorisés
avec des projets pilotes dans les villes
donc tout ça ce sont des démarches en
cours aussi quand on m'a déjà demandé où
les passes de kaka ie6 connaîtrions
et el hadj antisémite ou un loup
lapointe domoun
la route unité
notre histoire elle est immense donc
tout à chacun peut puiser un thème et
mettre en valeur sous forme de spectacle
ou d'activités scolaires
notre histoire elle est immense donc
tout à chacun peut puiser un thème et
mettre en valeur sous forme de spectacle
ou d'activités scolaires